the show begins in Paris in 1967 with a
chess Prodigy named Beth Harmon waking
up in her hotel room the other night she
had partied really hard and fell asleep
in the bath she suddenly remembers that
it is her big day to compete against a
man so she rushes downstairs as Beth
heads to the hotel lobby she keeps her
composure as Paparazzi flash cameras in
front of her after a while she
approaches her rival and the two prepare
to play as she looks the man in the eye
we see a glimpse of Beth's past in a
flashback we see a nine-year-old bath
surviving a horrific car accident on a
bridge however her mother died that day
the young Beth is now orphaned as her
father disappeared long ago she is sent
to an orphanage where the warden shows
her around she also encourages the
little girl to have faith and continue
progressing in life later Beth is
instructed to stand in a line where
other students are waiting for their
turn to receive some sort of vitamin
pills she befriends a student named
Jolene and the two chat around for a bit
shortly after Beth takes the pills and
immediately feels spaced out she even
starts struggling to walk around Jolene
notices this and reveals that she needs
to wait until night to eat the vitamins
during class the following day Beth is
sent to the basement to clean some board
dusters there she notices a janitor
named Mr shy Bell playing chess and
becomes curious Beth stares at him for a
while before heading upstairs that
evening while the students have lined up
to get their vitamins Jolene shows Beth
how to hide the pills inside her mouth
the little girl does this told and she
successfully sneaks the pills away
before going to bed she finally takes
the pill and starts getting zoned out
again at one point she even hallucinates
a chessboard on the ceiling of her room
days pass by and her curiosity for the
game keeps on increasing she regularly
visits the basement and watches Mr
scheibel play chess all by himself but
one day desperate to learn the game Beth
finally talks to him and requests that
he teach her chess however the janitor
simply says girls do not play chess this
upsets Beth but nonetheless she calms
her and demonstrates how much she's
learned already just by watching his
moves from afar Beth explains how each
of the pieces work and even talks about
a few tricks this impresses Mr chibel
and he finally allows her to play a game
unsurprisingly he beats her quite easily
that evening after Beth eats her vitamin
pills she again starts Imagining the
chess pieces but this time she can
calculate the moves and practice alone
the next few days Beth continues to play
chess against Mr chibel in the process
she learns different strategies and
tricks Beth's chest skills are further
sharpened when she reimagines the moves
on her ceiling at night this leads to an
eventual breakthrough as Beth beats her
master Mr chibel for the first time
slowly she begins to defeat him in every
game realizing that she may be the real
deal shibel continues to teach her
different formations and variations of
Chess all the while Beth stores up her
green pills to take in the evening she
even learns the popular chess move the
Queen's Gambit one day Beth heads to the
basement as usual and finds an unknown
man there Mr chibel introduces him as Mr
gonz from a chess club he has come all
the way from another city to play with
her surprisingly Beth beats him easily
clearly impressed by her moves Mr gonze
asks her where she practices and the
little girl replies I play in my head
following this Beth takes up a more
difficult challenge she plays both shy
Bell and gods at once with two separate
chessboards the odds are completely
stacked against her but to everyone's
surprise she wins both games
convincingly the following morning Beth
is called into the warden's office upon
reaching there she sees Mr gonze in the
warden having a meeting Mr gonze wants
Beth to join a chess club at a high
school every Thursday he wants her to
play everyone simultaneously since there
are rarely girls playing chess this
would be a great opportunity for both
Beth and the orphanage the warden thinks
about it for a while and approves it
much to the Delight of Mr gonze
afterwards Beth goes to get her vitamin
doses but learns that the orphanage has
changed their pills this worries her as
she has become addicted to the pills in
a sign of desperation she approaches
Jolene to ask for some of hers but the
latter tells her that she's only having
withdrawal symptoms the next day Beth
heads to the chess club but she isn't in
a good mood because of the absence of
the pills that she so depends on but
fortunately as she is about to leave
Jolene gives her a couple of pills and
wishes her good luck shortly after Beth
reaches the high school where a group of
Chess playing boys are present they are
surprised to see a girl and keep staring
at her dude put down the pawns is that a
female we learn that Beth has to play
all of the boys at once this is likely
the kinkiest thing these boys will ever
do as she takes them all on a crowd of
students gathers they are eager to
witness the girl getting humiliated
however to everyone's shock Beth
outplays every single opponent and ends
all the matches inside an hour and 20
minutes later she proudly tells Mr
chibel what happened despite her
Brilliance Beth's dependence on vitamin
pills forces her to act desperately
during a movie night she pretends to go
to the bathroom but breaks into the
orphanage Pharmacy she then starts
stealing pills and gobbles them up like
candy after a while she grabs the entire
pill jar and heads out Beth wants to
hide it in her room but unfortunately
before she can move she collapses due to
vitamin overdose the teachers and
students arrive at the same time and
catch her in the act in the next scene
Beth is being punished for stealing the
vitamin pills from today on she is
forbidden to practice Chess at the high
school upset she approaches Mr chibel
and informs him about the punishment she
then wishes to continue playing chess
with him as the years pass Jolene and
Beth become close friends they're now
the eldest in the orphanage one morning
Jolene reaches for a cigarette and heads
to the balcony as Beth gets up from bed
she joins Jolene and both of them spot a
car entering the orphanage grounds a
couple whom we know as Mr and Mrs
Whitley has come to adopt a child later
the warden calls every single student to
her office and the whitleys interview
them at last it's Beth's turn and she
manages to Captivate them with her
beauty and charm once the interview is
over she is asked to pack her belongings
Beth is officially adopted this takes
her over the moon but she is also sad
because she won't be playing with Mr
chibel again later Beth arrives at her
new house and the whitleys show her
around when they take her to her room
Beth is astounded by how much space she
will have for herself the next day she
wakes up to the wheatleys having an
argument about work-related matters Mr
Wheatley is about to leave on a business
trip and will be gone for two weeks we
learned that the couple isn't happy with
their marriage Beth heads off for her
first day of school and starts her life
as a normal teenager not surprisingly
she doesn't fit in with the kinds of
girls within the school most of them
make fun of her poor choice of clothes
to make matters worse Beth finds out
that there is no chess club in this
school the next day Mrs Wheatley takes
Beth to get some new clothes there she
sees some chess sets but Mrs Wheatley
refuses to buy her one as they are short
on money instead she wants Beth to start
saving bit by bit from her 40 cents
allowance so that she can buy one for
herself one day Mrs Wheatley asks Beth
to get her some packs of cigar threats
from the local convenience store
obliging to the request Beth heads out
and retrieves the cigarettes but as she
is about to leave the store she sees a
magazine related to chess however the
store owner doesn't let her read it for
free she needs to buy it Beth obviously
has no money so she steals the magazine
once home Mrs Wheatley mentions that
there isn't enough money to run the
house until the end of the month they
only get 70 dollars from her husband
Which is far less than they need how did
these people pass the adoption exam
hearing her worries Beth comes up with
an idea she wants to take part in the
chess competition the winner of which
will receive 100 there is a small catch
though the entry fee is five dollars
bath requests Mrs Wheatley to lend her
some cash but the latter straight away
refuses left with no choice Beth writes
a letter to Mr scheibel asking for five
dollars to enter the chess tournament
she also mentions that she will pay him
back double the amount when she wins the
tournament as she is about to send the
letter Mrs Wheatley asks her to run out
for another errand this time it is for a
prescription once again obliges and when
she gets the pills she realizes that
they are the same ones that the
orphanage used to provide later Mrs
Wheatley mentions that it is her
Tranquility medicine Beth hands her the
pill bottle but it is only half full as
she had already taken the other half for
herself now that she is reunited with
her vitamin pills Beth again begins to
practice chess on the ceiling the next
day she gets a letter from Mr chibel as
expected he has sent her the five
dollars with this Beth immediately
enters the chess tournament but when she
reaches the venue the organizers tell
her that there's no women's section they
also make fun of her and tell her to go
away however Beth is determined and she
asserts that there is no law that states
a girl cannot play chess because of the
rant the organizers reluctantly set her
up on The Beginner's list Beth's first
opponent is a girl and she defeats her
quickly afterwards she watches state
champions play each other in the second
round Beth beats her opponent and even
forces him to resign before ending the
day she has to play against a boy named
towns he is a Charming Man so Beth keeps
on Staring at him during the game
however this doesn't distract her from
the game and she easily beats him
despite the defeat towns is genuinely
impressed with how good she is for her
age when she returns home Beth finds Mrs
wheatley's room turned into a rack
apparently her husband left her and only
informed her over the phone the next day
Beth returns to the tournament to face
her last opponent Harry beltick the
state champion we learned that Harry has
arrogance about him he is so sure that
he will win the finals that he arrives
late to the tournament after the game
commences Harry immediately gets on the
front foot by displaying some impressive
moves feeling the pressure Beth heads to
the bathroom and Pops a pill to ease her
nerves she then returns with more
confidence and puts up a good fight at
last she eventually beats Harry and wins
the whole tournament because of this
Beth becomes a sensation in the local
papers of Kentucky she wins a hundred
dollars and heads home with the check
this Delights Mrs Wheatley and she
finally starts to acknowledge Beth's
skills it turns out that she didn't know
the game could pay so much the following
day miss this is Wheatley conducts an
Ardent and learns that a chess
tournament with prize money of 500 is
going to commence soon in Cincinnati she
informs Beth about it but the latter is
worried that she will miss school
fortunately Mrs Wheatley takes care of
this by lying to the principal that her
daughter is sick with this Beth agrees
to participate in the chess tournament
she then confidently asserts that she
will win the next morning we see Beth
and her mother arriving in Cincinnati
for the state tournament even here she
is well known by all the people they
call her the female genius wow even the
compliments are misogynistic her first
opponent is a nervous player who knows
her well before a game even starts he
admits defeat and wishes her good luck
what was that guy even doing here the
organizers from the earlier tournament
also show up to support Beth as they
have now become her number one fan they
have a discussion about participating in
the U.S open after that they talk about
the idea of playing in a Russian
tournament however they are skeptical
because it is believed that the Russians
are way better than the Americans at
chess in the next scene Beth wins this
Cincinnati tournament and gives her
mother 15 percent of the prize money as
a commission as time passes she goes on
to win various other tournaments around
the U.S our chess Prodigy is now more
and more popular and she draws attention
she is even interviewed by journalists
in her field in an interview Beth
reveals that she discovered chess in the
basement of her orphanage she also
explains that a janitor named Mr chibel
showed her some moves Beth also adds
that her great ability in chess comes
from the fact that she can predict how a
game will evolve and therefore play the
right way in order to win three years
pass and we see bath arriving in Las
Vegas in 1966 she is now a prosperous
woman who has the world at her feet
there she meets towns the Charming
opponent she met in Cincinnati towns is
now working as a magazine reporter and
he is here to write reviews on the chess
tournament he wishes to write an article
about bath and invites her to his room
to snap some photos for the paper Beth
agrees to follow him on the condition
that they play chess after the work is
finished God chess is so hot right now
once they arrive it is evident that
there is some chemistry between them
they are almost about to kiss but
unfortunately Town's roommate arrives
and ruins the moment in the next scene
Beth returns to her hotel room and finds
her mother drinking grabbing a bottle
herself Beth talks about her tournament
including her nervousness towards U.S
Champion Benny Watts he always has a
crowd around him and certainly knows how
to play later that day Beth runs into
Benny himself who discusses game
strategy the U.S Champion points out an
error that Beth made a few years ago he
explains that the previous player she
faced could have beaten her this
Revelation certainly rattles bath and
the most annoying thing is the fact that
Benny deduced her errors simply by
reading the report of the game the
following day Beth has to play the final
game with Benny although she manages to
keep a cool demeanor she begins to panic
eventually leading to her first ever
loss Beth is upset about her incapacity
to foresee what her opponent wanted to
do despite this she still gets a share
of the prize money just before Beth and
her mother leave Las Vegas towns rushes
after her and states that she'll have
another chance to face Benny in the
future the moral of the story is if you
want to be great at a game to see what
happens next watch the second part in
series recapped